elle est là avec nous ce jeudi c'est
notre ami et notre vie d'amour on
l'adorait l'horloge tout à l'heure
encore attendre il s'arroge tv
comment elle va celle ci tu me reconnais
c'est qui ba
isse christophe bardy
j'ai coécrit - oui on a passé un mois à
écrire un livre semble enfin sedan moi
j'ai passé un mois à écrire un livre
ensemble
de toi c'est marqué dessus cyril hanouna
avec christophe barbier ce que les
français ce que m'ont dit les français
ouais c'est sorti hier c'est super tu
l'as lu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
aucun flagrant délit d'oliver gaza
pas passer c'est pas toi qui écris non
mais c'est vrai que je dis beaucoup de
choses n'ont plus vraiment et je suis
étonné de l'accueil qu'il a reçu numéro
3 on peut d'ailleurs suggéré tony de
l'accueil qu'il a reçu merci voilà cyril
la semaine dernière tu m'as dit que tu
aimais l'opéra ouais c'est vrai et dans
ces cas-là 2011 bien sûr on l'a la scala
j'ai une petite surprise alors toi tu es
pro musica chanter jadot
je porte une écharpe au loup et se tire
sur tout ce qui bouge je suis le premier
déçu
je suis toujours mieux nabi jeu c'est
fait le poignet
je gagne tous les débats je suis tahrir
c'est booba je suis le barbier dessus
mais dynamique que ça dure
[Musique]
cyril
hanouna
[Musique]
jour legs loi
81 vas-y de plans
sur ma table de chevet j'ai l'intégrale
btp je suis le mardi elle aussi
alors contraint des français vont devoir
se livrer mais
je porte une cravate bleue je parle un
peu mes cheveux je suis le bas mais elle
aussi
bien que tu es l'âge de mon fils je n'ai
pas
si riche
et
tais toi
[Applaudissements]
puis city c'est bien ça quand sa fille
s'est pas posé pour l'argent je passe
pas je n'ai pas faim
[Musique]
on est des amis
non bon
répit
pour ça ça moi
[Musique]
ok bah tu ne vas pas
[Applaudissements]
j'en ai
et ce jusqu'au 31 décembre ils ont ce
talent
voilà on l'attend
là bas on va d'abord dans la tête
j'ai cru je vous trouve bien en
voiture les fenêtres ouvertes à fond il
faut vraiment
[Rires]